liberal soft on crime policies that
encourage shoplifting leading to
horrible consequences an 83-year-old
grandfather and Home Depot employee Gary
razor was just trying to do the right
thing and stop a thief from stealing
over 800 worth of pressure washers but
the low life shoved him to the ground
and Weeks Later Gary died due to
complications from injuries during that
attack the suspect is still on the Loose
as a medical examiner rules his death a
homicide thieves in North Carolina
basically have a license to steal if the
merchandise is valued at less than a
thousand dollars a shoplifter will get
slapped with just a weak misdemeanor
charge not even a felony Gary's son is
speaking out about the horrible crime
watch
it's just heartbreaking right I mean my
dad was uh just trying to do a job right
and and now he's now he's not no longer
with us so
um it's uh Paramount to me and my family
that we find this uh particular person
and that he uh receives the Justice he
so richly deserves
and robberies are getting so bad in
Philly a gas station owner had to hire
Kevlar vest wearing security guards
with AR-15s to protective store from the
city's rampant crime problem the
business owners tired of the nonsense
we are tired from this all nonsense
robbery drug trafficking racketings all
kind of hanging around your old gangs
they're forcing us to hire the security
high level security state level
overall though they do tell you in a lot
of these bigger stores if someone
shoplifts just let them do it
I guess maybe this is what happens
that's one way to handle the issue the
other is the way uh Saks or the big
stores on Fifth Avenue handle George
Floyd they put wire fences around and
armed guards like the Philadelphia
service station the problem Jesse is
that there has been a repudiation of the
social contract in the old days uh yeah
it's a little shoplifting here a little
shoplifting there but basically people
paid for what they took from those these
self-service stores that's how they
became so popular you know it was an
efficient way to do Commerce now there
is just this this uh this casual callous
Reckless disregard for the law it is uh
I'm going to do this I'm going to do it
but I I think that you will the Arc of
History uh will uh will solve this
because they will confront it with more
and more of the armed guards I remember
in the old days in the bodega judge you
probably remember this where they used
to put someone with a shotgun behind the
cashier so you come you stick up the
bodega say the reason the cops are there
is because it's been robbed 13 times in
three months there's a guy there who's
going to say stop and if you don't stop
you know it there will be a violent
response because Society cannot sustain
that kind of arrogant disregard for the
law and this guy is on the loose there
has to be video of them because there's
cameras all in these stores judge
hopefully we get them
well I mean if you if you have a law
enforcement agency that has the ability
to seek out individuals as opposed to
just enough law enforcement or police
officers to handle the crimes as they
come in you know you've got to have
Warren squads you have to have squads
that are looking for you know criminals
who are on the loose I mean police have
been defunded they don't have what we
used to have we're you know even I could
assign among my criminal investigators
you're doing this you're doing this and
you're doing this here's the issue and I
just want people to understand this this
guy once he's caught can be charged with
homicide he can be charged with a
reckless homicide there is causation
between the injury and you know the
defender will claim well if I did that
to a 30 year old he wouldn't have died
well you take your victim as you find
him okay so it is absolutely a homicide
that they're looking at this guy for the
problem is we live in a society that is
becoming you know more uh cold and more
inhumane criminals more embolden who's
just going to step up and do something
about this when we've got this this
social justice baloney that there's
proposing I mean at some point we'll
maybe get to what geraldo's talking
about but I don't see it happening when
you've got 10 robberies in Chicago in
two hours criminals are on high right
now and they know nobody's looking for
them nobody wants to arrest them no one
wants to get in a fight and this guy
dies because he's trying to stop a guy
from taking two power washers or
pressure cookers or whatever they were
and then in California this past weekend
a guy ends up coming out and shooting a
guy who was stealing from this uh
shopmart or whatever the guy he shoots
back at him and kills him and they don't
charge him uh with murder they're saying
it was self-defense wow so what's
happening is our society is now standing
down the law is protecting this stand
down people when they see this are
stepping back they don't want to get
involved or get shot and killed or
they're taking out their cameras we're
in a mess in this country yeah the
thieves used to hit the the warehouse or
they used to hit the trucks now they
just Waltz right into the store grab
what they want and stroll at it just
like you with the Christmas tree taking
a Christmas tree home from Fox imagine
the reverse I don't know how this
situation would play at the reverse that
Mr razor were alive but the offender was
dead
imagine how that would be covered right
right it would be he was a vigilante
this person was a victim of an oppressed
Society this happens barely a peep even
with video like that it's it's it's it
is clear that business is this large
probably tell everyone not to get
involved that's what insurance is for
but to geraldo's point there's a message
there and that message is contagious uh
Rob these places until they move out
this is a slow roll looting operation
they don't care if these buildings these
places leave that they don't care about
the people that are suffering because
they're they're whether they're mini
Marts or there are clothing stores are
being shut down or because of you know
riots they never reopened they don't
care so so the thing is you have the
insurance companies that are going to
well you know what we don't want anybody
to get hurt and at the same time well
they're just close close all of these
down but that this is like a
metaphorical snapshot of the last two
years you know we the casualness that
Geraldo talks about no fear of
repercussion and the reason why there's
no fear of repercussion because if there
is repercussions you're a racist you're
part of the the oppressive regime we're
still living in that post-ferguson era
where we allowed the media and we
allowed activists to tell us that law
enforcement is permanently stained
there's nothing you can do about it
right and even prisons so this guy was a
repeat offender Menace to Society
already known not in prison because we
we just we agreed with the assumption
that prisons Were Somehow offensive and
we should have less prisons not more we
need more prisons because right now we
were the eggs that are getting broken to
make this Progressive omelet
um you know where are reparations for
victims you know if we honestly believe
that the origins of all of these
problems or 400 years of Oppression and
slavery right and then that caused us to
change all of these policies no cash
bail reduce sentences
where are the reparations doesn't even
matter the color of the skin for the
criminal where are the reparations for
the criminal for the victims that were
killed attacked raped by people that
were let out based on the assumption
that all of these rules were racist or
oppressive based on 400 years of
persecution that's an interesting
lawsuit well I would hope that the
executives at Home Depot would do right
by this family yes and and and maybe
give some restitution there I I
certainly hope so they shouldn't have to
right like that
you just said something where's the AARP
yeah where's
who's standing up for him this he was 83
years old he loved to work he loved to
go to work his wife I was reading an
article about how much she misses him
the son obviously misses him the
grandchildren are going to miss him he's
83 years old healthy enough to go to
work every day and he was from the
generation as Jimmy Fallon pointed out I
want to give him credit for saying it
first that he's from the generation that
if they saw something they did something
and then we were from the generation if
you see something you say something and
now it's like just don't just pretend
you don't see it yes and then order it
from Amazon because you don't have to
worry about going to a store and getting
it and I also and what's happening to
the working class the gentleman who was
interviewed who's the shop owner who
said that they've been forced to hire
security this is an entrepreneurial
immigrant who is in our country who
wanted to take a risk he's he's doing
everything that America is offering and
we are not holding up our end of the
social contract for him do you know in
Washington DC the candy is behind the
glass now so you have to call a shop
person to ask them to go behind to get
you a Snickers bar that's how far this
is gone and gives you time to think
about getting the Snickers bar yeah and
you don't want to rethink that that's
the Silver Lining Jesse it's very
satisfying if you haven't heard anyway I
feel for this family and I do Wonder
like where where are the associations we
always asking them where where was AOC
when women were being attacked in New
York I think you're right when you go
back back to the idea of ordering
everything from Amazon we have we've all
retreated into our cubby holes and we
don't have to go out there except for
this guy that's working and if you think
about that limit it said like anything
under a thousand dollars this guy had
eight hundred dollars so it's not like a
shoplifting stopped it encouraged him
and then you have this this old this
poor old fella who's just looking at
this and going wow they're stealing
that's a lot of stuff they can lower
that can't they just get either the city
council or the state legislator to drop
it from 800 to 400 or 300 because the
criminals know the law better than most
people for the most part it is but
what's happening is prosecutors this is
hey we're going to ignore whatever
ceiling the the law reads and just say
we're not going to prosecute those
crimes if they prosecute them at all
yeah but this is a manslaughter yes
let's be clear this is not shoplifting
this is manslaughter absolutely all
right we're going to continue to follow
it hi winner Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interview is coming your way
on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now